Cyber security is one of the fastest
growing and most respected fields today
and earning your CIS certification can
open the door to some of the highest
paying and most trusted roles in the
industry. But passing the CIS isn't just
about memorizing facts. It's about
understanding how to think like a
security leader. That's exactly what
this course is designed to do. I will
walk you through every domain, simplify
complex topics and share real world
example that will help you not only pass
the exam but truly master cyber
security. So before we begin, like this
video, hit that subscribe button and
turn on the notification bell. This is
the domain one security and risk
management and your CIS journey starts
right now.
So hi everyone and welcome to this CIS
course. So before we dive in, let me
quickly introduce myself. I'm a cyber
security professional having over 16
years of IT industry experience. I have
worked across various domains mainly
computer networks and information
security. I hold multiple certifications
mainly the CIS, CISA, CCSP and the
network certifications from Juniper,
Huawei and many others. So the CIS exam
is basically based on eight domains and
and we can see the first domain security
and risk management is the heaviest and
it carries overall weightage of 16%. So
this domain also sets the tone for the
rest of the domain because we will
discuss the foundational concepts such
as the CIA triad, the risk analysis,
governance, different frameworks
and then the con these concepts will
basically be used in all of the rest of
the domains
and after the domain uh number one we
will study rest of the domains one by
one. I will try uh to explain the
concepts in a simple language and as
practical as possible.
So English is not my uh first language
or mother language. So there may be uh
some issues with my language with my
terminologies or with my flow of
communication. So uh you people need to
excuse me for that but I will need to be
uh I will try to be as clear as possible
and will try my best to explain the
concept regardless of uh my
communication skill uh in a best way
possible.
So the CIS exam is basically based on
the CAT exam format which is
computerized adaptive testing. What does
this mean? This means that uh you get a
question and if you uh get it correct,
you get uh the question right, the next
one may be difficult and if you get it
right too, the difficulty may increase
and if you miss a question or you get it
wrong, the next one may be right. So uh
it is uh called adaptive because the
difficulty and the difficulty level uh
is adjusted by the computer as per your
performance. So the length of the exam
is 3 hours and you may encounter
anywhere between 100 to 150 question.
The questions are mostly MCQs,
multiplechoice questions. But there may
be some drag and drop questions but
mainly they are MCQs. So why we don't
have a specific number uh and the number
varies between 100 and 150. So this is
because if you are doing very well let's
suppose if you are answering most of the
question let's suppose 90% uh you are
performing answering the question
correctly you may be stopped at 100
question number 100 your exam will stop
automatically and when you go to the
checkout counter you receive your result
you will be greeted with a very uh
welcoming print note of congratulations
that you have passed by attempting the
100 questions only. Similarly, some may
go up to 125 question. So when I was
attempted, I uh attempted one to five
question and then the exam stopped and
when I went to the counter uh I passed.
Some go all the way up to 150 question.
So it depends upon your performance.
Similarly, on the flip side, if someone
is performing maybe very poorly,
he or she is answering the question
incorrectly. And let's suppose 90% of
the question uh he or she answered are
incorrect. So again, he or she may be
stopped at question number 100 and the
exam may end automatically and the
result will be as uh expected.
So that is the passing score that out of
100 you out of 1,000 you need to get 100
700 points. So the exam is available in
multiple uh languages and uh it is need
to be given at the ISC to authorize
Person B testing centers. So now let's
get start with the actual content of
this course and our first topic is the
CIA triad and CIA is the
confidentiality, integrity and
availability and these are the main
goals are the basic goals of information
security. So confidentiality ensure
information is accessible only to
authorized individuals
and confidentiality of information can
be ensured through multiple means. For
example, through encryption. For
example, an encryption algorithm AES
that is advanced encryption standard can
be used to encrypt information so that
it is accessible only to authorized user
and even if unauthorized gains access to
this encrypted information they won't be
able to make sense of information
because they won't have the decryption
key. Next important pillar of the CA
triad is the integrity which ensures
data is accurate and unaltered
and integrity of information is mainly
ensured through hashing. For example,
a popular hashing algorithm is 256.
So we will study the encryption
different types of encryption similar
hashing algorithm in details in the
upcoming domains but for now these are
just for starter for the basic uh basics
of information security to rehash and
refresh your knowledge about the basic
concepts and the last pillar of the sale
trade is availability which ensures
information and systems are accessible
when needed. So this is important this
when because the information should be
accessible but also
timely accessible.
So if there is a lot of delay or if the
information is accessible not when
needed but but after a certain time it
means availability is compromised. So
availability can be ensured through
multiple means. For example, redundancy.
Redundancy means that let's suppose you
have a server where users are getting
let's suppose we have a client getting
services from this server and we have a
redundant server. So let's suppose if
this server fails due to any reason the
user can be redirected to this server
seamlessly without the compromise of the
availability of information.
So on the flip side of the CIA triad we
have dad which is disclosure alteration
and destruction. See so if
confidentiality is not uh ensured we
have the disclosure of the information
and if integrity is not ensured we have
alteration in information and if
availability is not ensured we have the
destruction of information. If
information is destroy destroyed or the
information infrastructure is destroyed
for example if the data center is
destroyed due to a natural disaster you
won't have the availability of the
services of information. So that you can
say disclosure is the flip side of the
CIA triad. So these are some of the
threats to the CIA to confidentiality.
The threats are social engineering, news
dropping and media use. So through these
threats the confidentiality of
information can be compromised. So
social engineering for example a hacker
calls a company and pretends to be from
the IT department and asks the employee
to give uh them the username and
password to fix an issue. So if the
employee is strict into giving his or
her username and password, it means the
information uh the confidentiality of
information of this company is
compromised. And this compromise was
done through social engineering when
hacker tricked the employee by giving uh
them giving the hacker the uh username
and the password. Similarly,
easedropping is sniffing on the
sensitive information. An example can be
given. Let's suppose if an employee of a
company is sitting in a cafe and using
the
free cafe Wi-Fi and this Wi-Fi traffic
is unencrypted and let's suppose there
is another hacker sitting over here that
is sniffing this information. So if this
employees sends a sensitive email to
another employee of the company and this
hacker sniffs on that information on or
use drops on that information the
confidentiality
of the information of that company is
again compromised media reuse let's
suppose a company has old PCs and wants
to dispose of these PC and these pieces
are sold to a third party or to another
company. So if the uh third party
retrieves the HDDs or hard drives from
this PC
and if the owner the actual owner of the
company has not made sure that the
information are these HDT are actually
wiped out. They simply formatted these
hard drive. The sensitive information
from these hard disk drives can be
retrieved by the company and thus the
confidentiality of information will be
compromised. Integrity threats to
integrity or corruption of the
information and malicious modification
of information. So corruption of the
information may be through let's suppose
a power outage. Let's suppose a database
server suddenly shut down due to power
outage and there was a corruption of
file in the database and some
information
was uh destroyed or uh was corrupted and
so the information the integrity of this
database or information is
uh compromised and corrupted. This is uh
modification means that let's suppose
there is an internal employee. Let's
suppose the DBA himself. So if the DBA
is uh modifies the payroll and increase
his salary in the payroll
uh without approval it means he has done
malicious modification to the
information.
So that is this type of threat is now
also known as insider threat because the
employer is insider.
He has the uh access to the information
but has done modification maliciously.
Similarly availability
threats to availability or denial of
service attacks such as DOS and DOS. So
these are the attacks where hackers
flood the company applications or server
with malicious requests and the servers
are the application are exhausting and
exhausted and not available to
legitimate users. Similarly natural
disaster are also threat to the
availability of information. So for
example, earthquake can knock down a
data center and if there is not a
redundant data center, the information
to all the user that were served from
this data center will not be available.
So another important triad besides CIA
is the AAA triad and the AAA stands for
authentication, authorization and
accounting also known as nonrepudiation.
So authentication is verifying the user
or system identity before granting
access and this can be done through for
example MFA or multiffactor
authentication. If we talk about single
factor authentication username and
password
this is also
username and password. This is also used
to authenticate a user. So
authentication is very important before
granting access to any user and uh a
system. The next step when the user is
authenticated and logs into a system or
application is authorization.
Authorization means ensuring user only
access what they are permitted to. So it
is not the case that when he or she logs
in he has access to all the information
available over there. There must be
something that is out of the role or out
of the reach of that specific user. And
this is mainly done through role based
access control. For example, the HR
department may have uh
specific functions which they can
perform through HR user. So this is uh
an HR uh user which have access to
specific such as as we talked about
payroll application
but not to other sensitive information.
Similarly uh if you talk about another
department finance so the finance
department may have access to other
information and that uh authorization
and access can be ensured through role
based access. So finance user will be
given the finance user role and the HR
user will be given the HR user role.
So the next important factor in the AAA
triad is the accounting. So accounting
is keeping track of user actions through
logging and auditing. So what is logging
and auditing? An example of a logging
and auditing is for example when a uh
user logs in to a server. The server log
shows the username the user through
which the user logged in the timestamp
at which the user logged in and the
action that they were performed by the
user. So the user at the later stage
cannot deny that he or she performed
those action because we have a clear
evidence of all the action that the user
performed and at specific time of time
frame. So this is also known as
nonrepudiation. It means the user cannot
deny having performed certain actions
due to the process of accountability and
auditing.
So another important concept is the
balance security. What does mean what
does we mean? What do we mean by the
balance security? Balance security means
that it uh should not be the case that
you should throw every piece of security
and information at the in at your
assets. The information security should
be balanced. So same rules do not apply
to all type of business. It mean that
information security should be tailored.
Security needs needs to be tailored
because let's suppose a hospital
protects patient data. So it may have
certain security requirements while a
retailer secures payments. So their
requirement of information security may
be different and the information
security system must be tailored
according to each organization and
requirements. So keep it to the
organization type as we studied. Let's
suppose if there is a small startup they
may they may need simple and less
control as compared to a larger banks
where we may need multiple control and
more complex controls.
Another important uh aspect is that the
information security must align to the
business goals. So this is very
important one. You may expect multiple
question uh uh regarding this concept
that the information
security
should
be the business goal. It should not
obstruct the business goal. It must
align to the business goal. So security
should enable not block the
productivities. So this is important and
you must keep in mind this uh concept.
You may encounter uh some question in
your exam uh relating to this concept.
Now coming over to some important
security definitions. So these will be
used in the upcoming slides these
concepts. So it is important that we go
through these uh one by one. So the
first one is the asset. So asset is
something valuable
to the organization that needs
protection. For example, the company's
customer database containing names,
emails and credit card details in an is
an asset to the organization and its
conf confidentiality, integrity and
availability must be protected. Another
concept is the vulnerability which is a
weakness that could be exploited.
remember and uh focus on the term
weakness. So for example the uh we may
have a software flaw or unpage security
hole in this customer database. So we
have an asset and if this asset that is
the database have some unpatched
security hole it means we have a
weakness or we have a vulnerability in
that customer database. Next concept is
the threat which is a potential event
that can cause harm. For example,
data theft or unauthorized to the
customer record. So if unauthorized
access to this customer database takes
place, we may say that we have a threat
of unauthorized access to this database.
So this is a threat. Next is the threat
agent which is the person or entity that
causes the threat. It is the agent or
the person that carries the threat. So
for example, a cyber criminal trying to
steal customer data. Another concept is
exploit which is the method or tool used
to take advantage of a vulnerability in
the system. So for example, a SQL
injection attack used to break into the
database
and last one is the risk which is the
potential impact or loss if a threat
succeeds in exploiting the
vulnerability. So an example of risk is
financial loss or reputational damage
due to the lead customer data. and these
financial loss and the potential damage
is to the organization.
Our next topic is security control
types. Security control can be divided
into three categories that is physical,
technical and administrative. We will
study each of these and their example in
a while. And they can also be divided
functionality wise. And by functionality
we can divide them into preventive,
detective, corrective, recovery and
detriment. So we will see uh what these
are as well as their examples. First of
all the categories. So first one is the
technical technical control are
basically hardware or software mechanism
used to manage access to resources and
systems and provide protection for those
resources and system. You can also say
as the name indicates these are the
control that are implemented uses
technology and technology in the form of
either hardware or software. Next cate
category is the managerial or
administrative. So these are the
policies and procedures administrative
controls defined by an organization
security policies.
So they basically constitute the written
policies and procedures. You can say
they are not uh hardcore
technical or physical control. They are
just instructions in the form of
policies as well as procedure. And the
last one, last category is the physical
which is security mechanism focused on
providing protection to the facility and
real world object. So by facility we
mean the physical building or
infrastructure for example the
you can say the data center.
Now coming over to few examples of these
uh categories. So the technical category
example include encryption, smart cards,
password, biometric, access control list
that is ACL, firewalls, routers and IDS,
IPS, intrusion detection and prevention
system.
The managerial control category example
include policies, procedures, vendor
management, hiring practices, background
checks, data classification, security
training, risk assessment and
vulnerability assessment. While the
physical uh category example include
guards, man traps, fences, lights,
motion detectors, guard dogs, video
cameras, alarms and
laptop logs. So these are our physical.
So as you can see when we go to the
security control uh distribution by
functionality wise we will see that
these uh examples fit into
uh different type of functional control.
For example the motion detector may be
detr as well as detective security
control. So let's now go to the so uh
before we go to the security control
types by functionality we can see that
these control basically works
uh in layer. So this type of model is
also known as defense in
depth.
So whenever we secure our assets we
apply these security controls in
different layers. This is also known as
another name for this is layered
defense
so that if one layer fails we have
control
at the next layer and so on and so
forth.
So the security control types by
functionality we have the data control
which is deployed to discourage
violation of security
policies.
Next one is the preventive. So they are
deployed to prevent or stop unwanted or
unauthorized activity from occurring. So
see the difference. This one is used to
discourage while this this one the
preventive is used to prevent or stop.
Detective is used to discover or detect
unwanted or unauthorized activity. So
simply by seeing the name you can make
sense that which type of control is
this? Compensating control provides
options to other existing control to aid
in enforcement of security policies.
Corrective control are measur taken to
fix security vulnerabilities or mitigate
damage after a security incident has
occurred and directive controls are
proactive measure designed to guide
behavior and enforce compliance with
security policies and procedure. So now
coming over to example of these uh
security control types. First one is the
detriment. So security guards, lighting,
security cameras, separation of duties,
security policies and security awareness
training. So you can see that these
security control may fit into multiple
types. For example, the security guards
may also be detective as well as
preventive. A security guard can detect
an intruder entering the facility. He
can also prevent the intruder from
entering the facility using any means
available to him. Similarly, the
lighting uh is also a detective control
as well as detrint.
Preventive control are fences, locks,
biometrics, man traps, alarm systems,
job rotation, data classification,
penetration testing, access control
methods and firewalls. Detective R as we
can see security guards is in detran as
well as in detective
guard dogs motion detector job rotation.
So how does the job rotation detect a
security control for example you have an
employee a working let's suppose in a
finance department.
So let's suppose now you rotate the job
of A and assign
B to the same finance department doing
the same function. So if A was doing
something
uh malicious now the B can see what A
has done and in this manner we can
detect the malicious activity mandatory
vacation. Similarly, if you send A on
leave and B fill the A uh job, you can
see we can again detect the
any malicious activity.
Similarly, audit trail as we study in
the form of logs, intrusion detection
system, violation report, honeys, etc.
Compensating controls are security
policy, personnel supervision,
monitoring and work task procedures.
Correctives are backup and restores.
So backup and restores as you can see
let's suppose you have a database and
you take regular backup of this database
and if there is an eventuality if the
database is corrupted or unavailable you
can restore the data from backup and
restore. So in this way it is corrective
patching. Similarly if there is a
security vulnerability you can patch and
correct correct the vulnerability.
Similarly antivirus anti-malware
forensic analysis and disciplinary
action.
Directive control are again policies
procedures standards guidelines physical
uh signage verbal instruction contracts
and agreement.
Now coming over to security program
development frameworks.
And the first one is the ISO 27,000
series. So these are basically
international standards on how to
develop and maintain ISMS that is
information security management system
inside an organization.
So we have two framework in this series.
The important one we have many but these
two are important. First one is the
27,000 one. So the focus of this one is
on the requirement for establishing,
implementing, maintaining and improving
the ISMS or information security
management system. And the second one is
ISO 27,0002.
So this one provides guidelines and best
practices for selecting and implementing
information security control listed in
the Nexure A of ISO 27,01.
So as you can see we will uh in the next
slide we will see the difference between
these two but here you can see this one
the two basically gives you the
guideline and best practices on how to
implement the 27,0001 and this is
basically the standard or the
requirement that should be used by the
organization to establish and implement
the ISMS inside their organization. So
what is the difference between these
two? So 27,01 is basically the
requirements that must be fulfilled to
establish an ISMS inside organization.
This define the ISMS framework on what
to do and this can be certified. Yes, an
organization can be 27,01
certified if the organization fulfill
these requirements. 27,0002 are
basically the guidelines on how to
implement the 27,01. So these 27,0002
explains control on how to do it. This
is what to do and this is how to do. So
you cannot certified uh the 27,0002.
This is just a guideline uh security
framework for the 27,01.
So now coming over to our next topic
which is the types of law and we have
these different types of law mainly the
criminal, civil, regulatory and
intellectual property and we will study
all these one by one in detail. So the
first one is the criminal law. So what
is the criminal law? So criminal law
basically deals with actions that break
the law and harm society. So remember
this uh thing this key word that these
are the laws that can be used to protect
the society. So the prosecutor must
prove guilt beyond a reasonable doubt
which can be heard in computer crime. So
in criminal laws since these are the
laws that result in even death the proof
must be beyond a reasonable doubt that
means the proof must be crystal clear. I
mean I think you understand the point
that in criminal law the you in order to
prove someone guilty the proof must be
beyond a reasonable doubt. Why? Because
the penalty in these laws are very high
such as fines, jail time or even
death in very serious cases. That why
the uh to prove the guilt the proof must
be beyond a reasonable doubt. Remember
this.
So types of uh you can say the uh
penalties or the types of crimes maybe
these may be felonies which are serious
crimes usually punished by more than one
year in prison or misdemeanors which are
less serious crimes and punished by fine
or less than one year in jail. So the
goal of the criminal laws are basically
to punish offenders and deter them from
committing similar crime or deter other
from committing similar crime. So these
laws are enacted to protect the harm to
the society. So remember these are the
laws to protect the harm to the society.
Next one is the civil also known as the
tort law. So these are the law that
handle disputes between private,
individual or organization. Remember in
the previous law the criminal law we
were dealing with the individual and the
society. Now we are dealing with between
private individuals or organizations
and the decision is based on
preponderance of evidence whichever side
seems more likely to be right. So this
is in opposed to the previous where the
uh proof must be beyond reasonable
doubt. Here it is prepoundonderance of
evidence that is whichever party or
whichever organization or individual
seems more likely to ride. For example,
if one individual seems to be 41% right
and the next one is 51% right, it means
that
this one
uh gets the decision in his or her
favor. While in criminal you must be you
can say that 99.9%
sure regarding the proof. So the result
is usually financial compensation. So in
this type of laws the punishment you can
say it is in the form of financial
compensation not jail time and the
damages can include compensatory which
cover actual losses including legal fees
the lost profit or the medical bills
may be punitive as well which is extra
penalty to punish the wrong door and
statutory which uh
statutory. So uh sorry if I don't
pronounce this word right. It is a bit
complex. So this is the fixed amount set
by law often used when the actual damage
is hard to calculate. So the civil law
may have specific amount
uh fix that must be paid if a certain
type of civil crime or civil law is
broken. So related terms include
liability, due care, due diligence and
the prudent person rule that is acting
responsibly like a reasonable person
would.
Next are the administrative or
regulatory law. So the regulatory law
you can say they are created by
government agencies to control and
monitor activities in specific
industries. For example, in uh banking
we have Basel 2 regulations. In energy
sector we have energy policy act
of 2005
and in healthcare we have HIPPA privacy
and security rules. So remember HIPPA is
not uh a criminal or civil law. You can
say it is an administrative
regulatory law.
And it deals with the healthcare. This
one is important. You should remember uh
HIPPA that what it deals with. It is
used to protect the confidential data of
patients and their medical records. It
is important. So the standard of proof
is again more likely than not unlike the
criminal and penalty are usually in the
form of fines or imprisonment for
violating regulations.
Now coming over to our third
law type which is intellectual property.
So these pro laws basically protects
creations of the mind such as
inventions, designs, artwork, music and
software. So as the name indicates these
laws basically protect intellectual
properties such as invention, design,
artwork, music and software. So a
company must actively protect its
intellectual property for example by
registering patents or trademark
otherwise it may lose its legal rights.
So if a company has not registered its
invention in the form of patents or
trademark it cannot then legally
challenge the other party of copying
their patents or trademark. So the world
intellectual property organization or
you can say vo is a UN agency that
oversees intellectual
international intellectual property
protection and cooperation. So common
violation of this law include licensing
misuse for example using something
without proper permission. If you don't
have a license of let's suppose a
software and you are using it is misuse
licensing misuse. Plagiarism for example
copying someone else's work for example
you can say someone thesis
piracy is illegal copying or
distribution of software and movies such
as in the form of you can you people
must understand and know the uh torrent
where these
movies and other stuff such as games and
uh music are distributed. So these are
illegal corporate espionage is stealing
trade secret or confidential
information. For example
uh stealing the
uh Pepsi secret recipe of their soft
drink. So this is their tra trade secret
and if someone tries to steal or someone
steal this uh trade secret it is against
the intellectual property law.
So what are trade secrets? So a trade
secret is information that gives a
company a competitive advantage like
formulas, processes or design. As I gave
the example in the previous slide, a
trade sample may be the formula of the
Pepsi cold drink.
It must be kept secret and protected
from unauthorized access or disclosure
and it is owned by the company and offer
essential for its success. So to qualify
as a trade secret the information must
be real, valuable and not easily
discovered or guessed by others.
Next is copyright. So copyright protects
the expression of ideas such as books,
music, artwork, videos or software not
the idea itself. So anyone can write
let's suppose uh a fiction book but a
specific fiction book let's suppose
named as uh
you can say a fiction book named as
This is a funny fiction book name Alion
King.
So if someone register their book with
the same name you can say or even copy
some content of this book this is the
violation of this copy right itself. But
you can write other uh fictional book on
the same topic but without copying the
original author ideas or name or other
thing. So the creator has the right to
control how their work is used, shared,
copied or sold. Protection starts
automatically once the work is created.
It does not have to be registered or
published. So the copyright is
automatically registered. The author
does not have to register or publish it.
As soon as it is created, it is
automatically protected. So the duration
of copyright is for an individual other
the lifetime of the other plus 70 years.
So for example, if the other is 70 years
old, then the
copyright is will be 70 years. You can
say let's suppose he created the
copyright at the age of 50. Then the
copyright lifetime would be 90 because
he created it at 50. So 70 plus 20 is
equal to 90. For a corporation, it is 75
years from the publication. So
limitation on copyrights are first sale.
So once a copy of the work is sold, the
buyer can resell the copy. For example,
reselling a book. Fair use allows
limited use of the copyrighted material
for purposes like education, research,
news or commentary.
The next intellectual property type is
the trademark. So trademark protects a
word, a symbol, logo, sound, color or a
design that identifies a product or
brand. So this prevents other from
copying a company's unique look or
identity. So you can uh say you can see
that each company has a unique symbol
and logo. For example, if you see at
Microsoft, it has a specific logo.
Similarly, the you can see at Nike, at
Apple, all these companies have their
specific symbol and logo and you cannot
copy them. For example, brand names, for
example, name Nike as well as the Nike
logo, this one. operating system uh
symbol such as the Apple uh symbol or
the Microsoft Windows symbol. So the
trademark law treaty implementation act
provides international protection to
trademarks.
So what are patents? So patents
basically protects new and nonobvious
invention for 20 years. So the copyright
was
the lifetime of the other plus 70 years
and for corporation it was 75. The
patent is valid for 20 years. So it
gives the owner exclusive rights to
make, use or sell the invention. For
example, cryptographic algorithm. An
individual may register
a cryptographic algorithm invented by
him as a patent and it will be valid for
20 years. It is considered the strongest
form of protection. Patents are
published to inspire new invention. The
patent corporation treaty that is PCT
offers international protection in over
130 countries. So owner must enforce
their own rights through the legal
system.
So this is now the summary of the
intellectual property. We have the trade
secret which is the which what it
protects. So it protects the
confidential business information that
gives a competitive advantage and it
must be valuable secret and protected
from disclosure and its duration is not
limited. It is as long as it remains
secret. For example, the Coca-Cola
recipe. Copyright is the original work
of authorship. For example, books,
music, software, art, and it protects
the expression not the idea itself. It
covers reproduction and distribution
rights. And its duration is author's
life plus 70 years and for individuals
and 75 years for corporation. Examples
include software code or a song or a
book etc. Trademark are the words,
logos, sounds, colors or symbols that
identify a brand. So these basically
distinguishes the product, prevents
copying of look and feel of the product
protected, it is protected
internationally and its duration is as
long as it's in use and renewed by the
company. For example, Nike logo or Apple
symbol pattern is the something new,
useful and nonobvious invention or
processes and it gives exclusive rights
to use and sell the invention to the
inventor itself. It is strongest
protection and published to inspired
innovation. it duration is 20 years and
example include cryptographic algorithm
or something some new hardware design.
So now coming over to our next topic
important topic US privacy laws. So this
one is important and some I have seen uh
some students and professional
overwhelmed by these laws uh due to the
sheer number of text
uh that are included in the books uh to
describe these laws. So uh I will give
the advice that you don't need to
remember each para that when these laws
were first published how many sections
are there in this law etc. You just need
to remember the more the main focus of
these law and you will be good to go.
For example, the first one we are first
talking about US then we will talking
talk about the global laws. So the first
US privacy law is we are specifically
talking talking about the privacy laws.
Privacy is dealing with the
uh confidentiality of
individuals and citizen
private data. Confidentiality of citizen
private data. So HIPPA deal HIPPA is the
health health insurance portability and
accountability act and its focus in
industry is of course the healthcare and
it protects medical and patient head
information and the term for this type
of data is PHI.
We have PII personal identif
identifiable information and PHI for
patient health information.
Next is the G LBA. This one is also
important which is Gro Liy act. So this
law basically deals with the financial
uh industry or financial sector and this
one safeguards customer financial and
personal data. So again we were talking
about the uh individuals and personal uh
data. So when it is their medical data,
it is dealt with by the HIPPA. When it
is their financial data, it is dealt
with by the GBA. So you if you remember
that GBA deals with the protection of
the financial data of the customers or
the personal inside US, you are good to
go. COPA next is the uh COPA that is
children online privacy protection act.
So it is uh deals with the industry of
online services for children for example
online services such as in YouTube etc.
And the main protection goal that this
law provides is the it limits data
collection from children under nitrine.
So remember this laws deals with the
protection of uh children privacy or you
can say children uh under uh under 13
children data. PCP CP RA that is
California consumer privacy act or right
acts. So it is general consumer privacy
and it gives California residents
control over their personal data which
is right to access delete and opt out of
sale. FISMA is federal information
security management act. This one is
also important
and its focus is federal agencies at it
ensure security and privacy of
government information
systems. Next is the cloud act that is
clarifying lawful overseas use of data
act. So this is not the uh cloud Amazon
cloud or you can say AWS. This cloud
stands for clarifying lawful overseas
use of uh data act and this one deals
with the data stored abroad and you can
remember this in inside the cloud. Cloud
uh is also distributed form of data
storage. So cloud also store data
abroad. So you can remember this law uh
through this minomic. So this law
basically allows US law enforcement to
access data held by US companies
overseas. So cloud act basically deals
with the protection of data stored
outside the US.
So now coming over to some global
privacy laws and the first one and the
most important one is the GDPR that is
general data protection regulation and
this one deals with the region and uh of
European Union or EU and it is
comprehensive law protecting personal
data and privacy rights of individual.
So if you see at the tax that is written
under GDPR it is very extensive. So you
should not be overwhelmed or intimidated
by that that tax. You should just
remember that what this law deals with
what it protects where is its
jurisdiction. So I remember when I was
giving the exam there was a question
regarding uh some company uh having to
protect the
personal data of citizen and that
company was in Germany. I remember this
particular question and the question was
that which law would be applicable to
this scenario and there were multiple
option one one was the GDPR. So if you
remember that uh if you know that
Germany is in EU and if you know that
the
privacy of the EU citizen is dealt with
by the GDPR then you know the correct
answer. So always remember that
this is not about uh cramming or
memorizing the facts and data. It is
about understanding the context,
understanding the concept. So next is
the uh 27701.
It is again its scope is all over the
world international and it is a
framework for managing and protecting
personally identifiable information or
PII and it is an extension of ISO 27,01
which was to create the ISMS framework
five B you can say PIPDA it is personal
information protection and electronic
documents act and this jurisdiction or
region is Canada. It regulates private
sector use of personal information.
Next is the privacy act of 1988.
It is applicable in Australia and it
defines rules for handling personal data
under the Australian privacy principle
that is a name is API
which is act on the protection of
personal information. It is applicable
in Japan and it governs how organization
collect and use personal data. Next is
PDP is personal data protection act
which is a Singaporean law and it again
controls collection use and disclosure
of personal data.
So next is the PCIDSS
that is payment card industry data
security standard. So this one is not a
legal mandate. So remember this is
important points that this is not some
regulatory or legal law. It is not a
legal mandate. This is a standard. Okay.
So it is a payment card industry.
Payment card industry self-regulate its
own security standards through this PSI
PCIDSS.
It applies to any business worldwide
that transmits processes are stored.
payment card transaction to conduct
business with customers. Compliance in
enforced by the payment card vendors and
compliance requirements are dictated by
the number of transactions as well as
any previous security
issues.
So now coming over to these important
concepts what are what are policies
standard baselines
guidelines and procedures.
So these uh what are these terms? What
are their definition? Their purpose some
example and whether they are mandatory
or not. First one is the policy.
Remember you will encounter many
question inside your CIS exam regarding
the policy what it is who is responsible
for it what it deals with. So policy is
basically a high level. Remember when we
see a high level we mean the uh
executive level such as CEO or CFO. It
is high level statement of management's
intent or direction. So policy is given
from the highest level of management
such as CEO CFO and the purpose is that
it defines what must be done. It sets
overall goal and expectations. For
example, if we uh give an example of
policy, all company devices must be
protected with strong passwords. So this
is a highle statement. It does not
defines what does mean by strong
password? What will be the length of the
password
etc. So these details are then given in
the standard or baseline etc. So is it
mandatory? Yes, it is mandatory for the
employees or the company to follow the
policy.
Next is the standard. So it is the
mandatory rule supporting the policy. So
see this is the highest level document
and then this is supported by these
other documents such as standard
baseline procedure and guidelines. It
defines specific requirements that must
be followed. For example, a standard uh
example can be given that password must
be at least 12 character long and it
must include letters, numbers and
symbols. So we have set a standard that
this this is how strong the password
must be. So as we can see this was most
generic. Now we are coming towards
something specific that the password
must be this is we have set a standard.
So we cannot go below the standard. The
password cannot be 11 character long and
it must include letter number and
symbol. So again yes it is mandatory to
follow the standard as well. Next is the
baseline. It is the minimum level of
security that must be met. As the name
indicate, this is the base level of
security that must be implemented. So
the purpose of baseline is to ensure
consistent security across all systems.
What does this mean? This mean that if
you have 100 systems and let's suppose
you you have set a baseline that the
systems must have antivirus installed
and p uh all server must have antivirus
and latest security pages installed. It
means this is the minimum level of
security. This is a baseline that must
be implemented on all the system. So
again, yes, baseline is also mandatory
to follow. Procedures
are step-by-step instruction on how to
carry out a task. So it defines how to
do it in detail. For example, steps for
resetting a forgotten password. And
again, yes, procedures are also
mandatory to follow. You should follow
all the steps of a procedure so that the
task is carried out in an appropriate
manner. And last one is the guideline
which is recommendation and a flexible
practice. Remember the word flexible. It
means it it is not mandatory. It can be
done or it can be left off. So the
purpose is that it provides advice and
not mandatory action. For example, it is
recommended to change the passwords
every 90 days.
So it is a good recommendation
uh and a good practice that the password
should be changed at least every 90 days
but if the employee don't do it is not
mandatory it is optional.
So as we can see this is policy is at
the highest level it is from the high
level management. It is their intent or
you can say it is their
vision.
Then we have specific standard. These
are specific mandatory rules. Baseline
are the minimum security level that must
be set at all system and it gives
consistency to system. Procedure of
step-by-step instruction and guideline
are recommended best practices. So
besides uh this guideline all these are
mandatory guideline is recommended but
not mandatory it is optional.
So now coming over to a very important
topic of this domain that is risk
management. So a definition of the risk
management. So risk management is the
process of managing risk associated with
the use of information technology. It
involves identifying, assessing and
treating risk to the confidentiality,
integrity and availability of an
organization's
asset.
So
we have some risk definitions. We have
different terms associated with the risk
and we will define these. So risk is the
chance that a threat will actually
happen as we studied in our uh initial
slides.
So controls are basically protection
used to reduce risk or you can also say
used to mitig mitigate risk and controls
uh can be physical as we studied such as
logs. They can be administrative such as
policies or technical such as firewalls.
Controls are also sometimes called
safeguards or counter measures. So then
we have another terminology of total
risk which is the risk before any
protection or any control is applied. So
when there is no control applied then
this the asset is having a total risk
and the residual risk is when uh
residual risk is the risk that remains
even after protection. So remember you
cannot completely eliminate the risk.
You can as we uh studied in the
definition reduce the risk. You can
reduce the risk or uh lessen the risk
but you cannot completely eliminate it.
That why we have a residual risk which
is the risk that remains after you apply
the control or protection. So remember
the protection, control, safeguard,
countermeasure, they are used
interchangeably. Secondary risk is a new
risk that appears after trying to fix
another one. What does this mean? This
mean that let's suppose you installed
let's suppose a firewall to remove a
risk. Risk was from hackers from
intrusion. So you installed a firewall.
Now you have a secondary risk that this
firewall uh is also
uh a point of failure. For example, if
your firewall let's suppose suddenly
shuts down, you may have uh
unavailability of services. So you have
a secondary risk that was introduced
when you tried uh to eliminate the first
or primary risk. Incident is when a risk
actually happens. So incident occurs
when uh risk actually occurs or happens.
So what are some uh what are the risk
management steps? So the first one is
the risk identification. Second one is
the risk assessment. We will study all
these one by one in detail. Next is the
risk mitigation and last one is the risk
evaluation.
So the first one was the risk
identification. So it is
self-explanatory. It is is used to
identify the risk and identify and
assign value to asset. So the first uh
uh step inside the identification is
that you must identify the asset and
then assign the values to the assets. So
some assets may be of high value, some
may be of low value so that you can
apply control accordingly. you cannot
apply all the control to all the assets.
Next is to identify threats and
vulnerabilities that could affect them.
So you identify the assets, you identify
uh their value and then you identify the
threats and vulnerabilities that could
affect these assets one by one.
So next step in the risk management is
the risk assessment. After you identify
you assess the risk. So assessment risk
assessment determine the level of risk
that is posed to each asset or the level
of risk for each asset. And we have two
methods to uh assess the risk. One is
the quant qualitative. This is based on
judgment or rating. For example, in this
type of risk assessment, we use the term
high, medium or low. Next is the
quantitative. It is based on numbers and
financial values as the name indicates.
It gives you a concrete quantity and it
is also sometime known as the it is
measured in dollars. So for example, if
you have an asset, let's suppose give me
an example a firewall. So you can say
that this firewall is worth
2,000
USD. So this firewall quantitative value
is 2,000 USD. So the qualitative example
may be given for example a reputational
damage. So you cannot uh quantify the
reputational damage easily in the form
of USD. You can say that reputational
damage is low, medium or high due to
this particular risk.
The third step is when you identify
assess the risk. The third step is to
mitigate the risk or your response to
the risk. So this step decides how to
handle each identified and assessed
risk. So these are important these
terminology you can your risk mitigation
strategy or response may be either to
reduce the risk that is to apply control
to lower the risk.
So if you apply the control and reduce
the risk you
again you will have the residual risk
but it will be
less than the total risk and it will be
manageable for the organization. You can
either accept the risk. This is
acknowledging the risk and taking no
further action. So this is uh this one
is maybe seems strange to you. For
example, if uh you have let's suppose
you have a threat of fire to your
organization and let's suppose if fire
occurs and you calculate that it may uh
damage property worth let's suppose uh
50,000
USD
this is you can you calculate that this
is maybe the annual damage from fire
threat and if If you do apply the
protection let's suppose you if you buy
the insurance from this their cost is
let's suppose 100k USD
so you can see that the protection is
costly than the damage itself in such
scenario we accept the risk next is the
transfer risk transfer uh transferring
the risk which is shifting the risk to
another party whenever there is a
transfer term there is always the
insurance or outsourcing. So you ensure
you do the insurance
for example as we study in the form of
this fire insurance or other cyber
security insurance. So this is you do
the uh transfer the risk to another
third party in the form of assurance or
outsourcing.
Avoid is eliminating the activity
causing the
risk. What does this mean? This means
that let's suppose an organization was
planning to
uh let's suppose develop a new data
center in a earthquake prone area.
So if the organization all together
uh decides
to not develop that data center due to
the risk of earthquake they have all
together avoided the activity of develop
developing the data center. I hope this
makes sense. So first they were uh
developing the data center in a
particular area but there was a risk of
earthquake. So now they have eliminated
or they have decided not to develop
there. So they have eliminated the
activity altogether and they have
avoided the risk. Last one is the reject
which is not the recommended one. It is
to ignore or deny that the risk exists.
So this one is uh particular one that is
not recommended. You can do any of the
these four but not this one.
And the fourth step is the ongoing
controls and evaluation. So once you do
all uh identify the risk, assess the and
mitigate the you should not stop there.
You should continuously monitor and
review controls to ensure they remain
effective.
So now coming over to the risk
assessment methodologies as we studied
risk assessment or risk an analysis.
First one is the qualitative. So as we
studied it is based on subjective
judgment to estimate the likelihood and
impact of risk and this method helps
prioritize which risk need attention
first and we may use the deli technique
which is the expert opinion to reach
agreement.
So this is just on the judgment as we
studied that we use term high, medium or
low.
So for example uh this can be on your
judgment that the
damage or the threat of fire to our data
center is medium or low or high. And
these can be done or multiple scenarios
such as environmental scenario, past
history, the structure of the building
whether it is made of wood, concrete
etc. So this is qualitative.
Quantitative is where you assign a
monetary or dollar value to each risk
event. It is more detailed and complex
and require special skills. It is used
for business decision and cost benefit
comparison. So you can do comparison
that how much the control cost and how
much is actually the assets worth and
then you can do the business decisions
and it depends on qualitative data to
identify identify and describe risk
before measuring them.
So it is not qualitative data. It is
basically quantitative
data. It is quantitative
because uh we are now dealing with
numbers such as dollars etc. that how
much an asset is worth in dollars and
how much a uh damage in term of dollar
can a threat uh posed to that specific
asset.
So again qualitative assessment it
assesses risk based on subjective input
and it uses terms like high, medium, low
and this one is inexpensive and quick
way to begin the prioritization and
ranking of race. For example, this table
shows that uh this
uh here we have the impact that what
will be the impact of or consequence of
a specific risk and what is the
probability of or likelihood of this
risk being occurring. And then we have
high, medium, low, low, medium, high.
And these number are the number of risk
that resides in the high, medium or low
categories.
Quantitative requires more experience
than qualitative analysis. It uses
mathematical calculation to assign a
dollar value to each risk and it help
make business decision based on
measurable data. In terms of dollars,
the goal is to find the financial impact
of a risk and decide the mo decide the
most cost effective control for the
asset. It is essential for performing a
cost benefit analysis when choosing
security measures.
So this table is important. It is the
quantitative analysis formulas and
terms. So these formulas are then used
to determine the quantitative analysis
of specific assets. So the first term is
the asset value. It is the dollar value
of an asset to the organization. For
example, a customer database may be
worth $100,000.
Next is the EFR exposure factor. So this
is the percentage of asset value lost or
damaged if a risk happen. For example, a
fire could destroy 25% of the database's
value.
Next is the SLE that is single loss
expectancy. So this is the cost of one
risk event. So if fire occurs once the
database will be uh destroyed 25% and
this is known as SLE. So SLE is
the asset value multiplied by exposure
factor. So the asset value in our
example were 100,000.
The uh damage or the exposure factor
from a single event was 25%. This is
0.25. So our SLE value is 25,000.
Next term is the ARO or the annual rate
of occurrence. So this is how often a
risk is expected to occur in a year. So
if the risk occurs two times in a year,
ARO will be two. If it occur 10 times,
ARO will be 10. And if he it occurs
every once every 10 the arrow will be 1
by 10 or.1.
So if a file is expected once every 10
year the arrow will be.1 and if the file
is expected to occur 10 time each year
the arrow will be
10. So I hope you remember uh you
understand the concept. If uh always
remember if there is any issue uh in
understanding specific term or formula
or terminology you can always write me
inside the command and I will reply
there and uh it is a good method for
other as well to learn uh as a community
when you post the comment and if you
people like you can also write in the
comment that uh I should do live uh
interaction. I can also do live
interaction after uh a specific domain
or for a specific domain so that we can
discuss these thing interactively.
So the next terminology is the AL that
is annual loss expectancy. So it is the
expected yearly loss from a specific
risk. So the formula for AL is so these
formulas are important you should know
them. Formula for a is SLE. We
calculated SL over here multiplied by
ARO
and so in our this particular example SL
was 25,000 a.1
so our AL is 2500 per year A is annual
loss expectancy
total cost of ownership or TCO it is the
total cost of applying a safeguard
including the setup and maintenance. So
for example, a backup system system
costing 5,000 setup plus 5 years
maintenance.
So what will be the TCO
uh for a year? It will be 5,000 plus 500
or 5500. So return on investment is the
money saved or gained from using a
safeguard. So if the control sells 2500
a year, the return on investment shows
if it's worth it. So
since this is one time cost, if you
apply this one time, the annual
maintenance is only 500. So you can
decide that it is worth it because the
annual cost due to this uh risk is 2500.
So this investment is worth it. So you
can see that when you apply this formula
you determine the TCO ROI in the form of
dollar and then you can decide whether
you should apply this
safeguard or not.
Another important concept is the
business continuity and disaster
recovery planning. So what is BCP or
business continuity planning? A BCP
basically ensure the organization can
continue essential operations during and
after a disruption like cyber attacks,
power loss or natural disaster. And the
focus of BCP is that the business should
be running with minipal minimal
downtime.
Next is the DRP. So what is then
disaster recovery plan? So a DRP focuses
on restoring IT systems. So this is the
key difference between the BCP and DRP.
DRP is specific to the IT systems data
and the IT infrastructure after a
disaster.
This term, this terminology, this phrase
is very important. You should know that
DRP is a subset of DCP. So BCP is
overall umbrella term. you can say it is
the big terminology and the DRP you can
say it is a subset of BCP and it deals
specifically with the technical
recovery. So this slide is important you
should know these terminology that DRP
deals with the technical recovery such
as restoring IT system database
infrastructure of the data center etc.
While the BCP deals with the overall uh
continuity of the operation including
the HR including the facility including
the uh other infrastructure for sitting
of the employees etc.
So again what is the difference between
BCP and uh DRP? So the focus of BCP is
continuous business operation while the
focus of DRP is to restore IT
restore IT systems and data
and the scope of BCP is
organizationwide. It includes people,
processes, facilities as well as IT. So
the scope of you can say BCP is wide.
It includes all the things inside
organization while DRP scope is narrow.
It scope is mainly IT and data
recovery.
So the goal of BCP is to maintain
essential all essential function while
the DRP goal is recovery of technology
and data. timing is BCP is applicable
during and after disruption while
another important difference is DRP is
after disruption after disruption occur
as the name indicate it is disaster
recovery.
So we often use the term recovery with
the data recovery or database recovery.
So you recover something after it is
lost. For example, your database is
corrupted. Now you want to recover. You
can recover it from the backup. So it is
after the effect that the disruption or
risk has occurred while the BCP is
during uh and after the disruption.
Another important terminology and
concept is the BIA or business impact
assessment. So BIA identifies and ranks
business processes and resources by
their importance to the organization. It
helps finds and evaluate risk whether
from internal sources or third parties.
So BIA consider both the probability and
impact of disruptions to the processes
business processes and resources. It
uses quantitative metrics like cost or
downtime to set clear priorities and it
helps decide which system or functions
to recover first during an incident. So
as we can see the name indicate business
impact assessment. What are some of the
processes or resources
that if impacted by a disruption will
impact overall business? So you identify
these processes, these resources, you
prioritize them and then you decide that
which functions or which resources you
should recover first during an incident.
So what is the relationship between BIA,
BCP and DRP? So BIA is it basically
finds and ranks critical business
functions, estimates impact of downtime
and sets recovery priorities.
And the uh BIA is basically the starting
point. It tells you what to protect and
how fast it must be recovered. BCP
business continuity plan ensure business
operations uh continue during and after
a disruption. It uses the BIA results.
So remember BIA is the starting point.
BCP uses the BIA result to design
strategies for keeping the essential
services running. So this is the first
this is the second and then DRP
basically focuses on restoring
the IT system data infrastructure after
a disaster. It is a subset of the BCP
and it supports BCP by handling the
technical recovery steps identified as
priorities in the BIA. So you can say
that basically BIA
is basically input
to both the BCP
and DR.
So BIA continued. So we have some
terminology associated with the BIA.
These are MTD that is uh maximum
tolerable downtime. MTO maxable to
tolerable outage. So these are basically
the longest time a function can be down
before it causes unacceptable damage to
the organization.
Uh it defines the upper limit of
acceptable downtime and what does uh
what happens if the upper limit is
crossed we uh start the BCP and DRP
processes.
RTO or recovery time objective. It is
the target time to restore a function
after disruption. It must be less than
the MTD or maximum tarable downtime.
This is important uh sentence. So the uh
RTO
recovery time objective should be less
than MT
because MTD is the maximum downtime that
an organization can afford. So you must
recover the function through RTO and it
should be less than MTD and it guides
how quickly recovery plan should work.
RPO is the recovery point objective and
it is the maximum amount of data loss
the organization can tolerate in time
for example 2 hours data loss 3 hours
data loss it determine how often backup
should occur so for example if your RPO
is let's suppose RPO is equal to 4 hours
so it is the uh
maximum amount of data loss the
organization can tolerate. So you your
backup should occur backup frequency
should less should be less than 4 hours.
For example you can say that your backup
occurs after each 3 hours. This is one
backup again after 3 hours you take
another backup. So if you take backup
here and disruption occurs over here uh
it means your data loss is less than 4
hours or your RPO is intact.
So this is uh as I explained this is uh
also explained in this diagram. So this
is the loss of data and this is your uh
downtime. This is where disaster occurs.
I hope it is understandable. This is uh
which I des described in our so RPO is
also in the form of time. RTO is also in
the form of time.
So how do we uh plan the BCP its
approval and implementation? So the PLO
plan approval is should be done by the
CEO if possible. He should endorse the
plan. He or she should endorse the plan
otherwise another senior officer can do
it and it indicates dedication of the
business to the process of business
continuity planning. Then you need to
plan the implementation. So you need to
create implementation guide and
schedule. Deploy resources to implement
the BCP plan and supervise the
maintenance of the plan. You also need
to train and educate the employees on
the BCP. You need to distribute the BCP
plan on need to know basis. So it is
should be distributed only to those that
need to know the plan. Everyone should
get at least an overview of the plan.
So this slide introduces personal
security controls which is a fundamental
administrative and procedural method
used in security governance. This slide
basically focuses on preventing fraud,
misuse or error by ensuring that no
single individual has excessive rights.
So the first personal security control
is separation of duties. Separation of
duty means that no single person should
have all the authority or control over a
critical process. This reduces fraud or
mistakes.
For example, one employee approves
payment in a system while the other
issues the checks or issues them. If
both these processes were done by a
single employee, he could issues the
payments to himself or herself, thus
committing fraud.
Split knowledge is a sensitive process.
Split knowledge is the method in which
sensitive process is divided so that no
one person knows all parts of it. So the
sensitive process may be a password
maybe some other information. For
example, two employees each know half of
an encryption key so that neither can
use it alone. So both the employees will
be needed to use the encryption key
rotation of duty. So employees
periodically switch roles or
responsibilities to detect fraud and and
improve skill coverage. As we already
studied,
an accountant sweps roles every few
months so irregularities can be parted.
Two person control is two authorized
individuals must act together to
complete a sensitive task. So launching
a missile or accessing a secure w
requires two people turning keys
simultaneously.
What is m of n control? So out of n
authorized people a minimum of m must
cooperate to perform a critical
function. Similarly uh such as we
studies in
uh separation of duties. For example, if
we have total five number of executive
then three or five or three executive
must agree to approve
or must approve to access the company's
encryption fees.
Next our next topic is the hiring
practices. So these are some of the uh
procedures
that involve or stages that involve in
hiring and firing the employees. So
first one is the onboarding. So on
boarding is the process of bringing a
new employee into the organization
including setting up accounts and
access.
So the purpose of onboarding is that it
gives only the minimum access needed for
their role or for the new employee which
is also known as the principle of least
privilege. So for example, if the new
employee is in the finance department,
he or she should be given the role
inside the finance group, not in HR or
other department and should be given
only the minimum necessary rights to
perform their duty. Next is the
background check. So verifying an
applicant's history, identity and
possible criminal or financial use
before hiring. So this helps ensure the
person can be trusted with sensitive
information or system. So you can say
this one is a detective as well as a
preventive control. It detects
uh an uh you can say a threat before
occurring and it also prevent a threat
so that it can be eliminated before it
takes place. Termination is the process
followed when an employee leaves
voluntary or in voluntary.
So it is necessary to revoke all access
of the terminating employee immediately.
Collect collect the company assets such
as ID, laptops, any other devices and
conduct the exit review. Security
awareness training is the ongoing
education for all employees on security
policies, threats and best practices. So
this helps employees recognize fishing,
handle data properly and follow security
protocols.
So our last topic is the code of ethics.
So these are known as canons and we have
1 2 3
and four. So we have four cannons. These
are uh mandatory to be followed by the
uh security professional. These are the
ISC2 cannons.
So these are important to remember and
the first one is to protect society the
common good necessary public trust and
confidence and the infrastructure.
The cyber security professional must
prioritize the safety and security of
the public and critical systems above
personal and organizational interest.
So remember that uh we have we are
protecting uh society, common good,
public trust, confidence and
infrastructure. So remember the order of
these uh the words and the you can say
the topics
uh inside each canon is also important.
So if you are uh to choose between the
infrastructure and the society or the
public trust you should protect the
society first. Similarly, act only uh
honorably, honestly, justly, responsibly
and legally. So, always follows the law,
be truthful and act with integrity in
all professional activities. In the same
manner, if you are given uh
the choices,
you should follow this order. You should
first act honorably, then honestly,
justly, responsibly, and legally.
So there are two thing one is uh to
choose between legality and uh to act
honestly and honorably. You should act
honorably and honorably then legally.
Third one is provide diligent and
competent service to principal. So
perform duties carefully and skillfully
for your employers or clients ensuring
quality and responsibility. And the last
one is to advance and protect the
profession. So contribute to the
reputation and growth of the cyber
security field by sharing knowledge,
mentoring and upholding ethical
standards.
So thank you so far for watching this
video. That's all for domain one. So
please like this video, share it in your
groups with your peers and if you have
any questions or any insight or
suggestion, please write them in the
comment so that we can discuss the
topics further if there are any doubts
for the benefit of us all. So I will see
you in the video two on the domain two.
So see you soon. Take care and bye.